hi in this module i'm going to show you
how you can take some real world
problems and model them as constraint
satisfaction problems
so we'll begin with our first example
so lsat is the standardized test for a
mission into law school and it features
these logic puzzles so here's one
example of a logic puzzle so imagine you
have three sculptures a b and c
that are to be exhibited in two rooms
one or two of an art gallery
so the exhibition has
imposed a certain number of conditions
on you
so sculptures a and b cannot be in the
same room
sculptures b and c must be in the same
room
and room two can hold
only one sculpture
so how do you model this as a constraint
satisfaction problem let's do it via
this javascript demo
erase that and start over
so
um the first thing you want to do when
you model is you figure out what the
variables are
so looking back here we want to
put the three sculptures in rooms so
let's just define a variable for each of
these sculptures
so
in this javascript demo i'm going to
define a variable
a
and the domain of that a is either one
or two depending on what
room
that sculpture a should be placed in
and i hit step and
i get this
actually
a variable and i can mouse over and can
see the domain of that variable
okay so now i can do it for the other
two
sculptures b
and c
um and you'll see that now i have three
variables a b and c each of which can
take on values one or two
so now let me define the factors
so i'm going to define a factor for each
of these three conditions usually each
condition corresponds to a factor but as
we'll see later that's not always the
case
so the first condition says that
sculptures a and b cannot be in the same
room
so this naturally is a factor that um
touches variables a and b
so i'm going to call that factor a b
it's a scope is
variables a and b
and remember a factor is a function
that takes on an assignment to the
variables in that scope
a and b in this case
and it's going to return a non-negative
number
in this case i want it to be that case
that a and b are not in the same room so
i'm going to return a not equal to b
so
um if i hit enter that is going to give
me this factor and i can check its table
that says 1 2 is good 2 1 is not
uh 2 1 is also good but
1 1 and 2 2 are not good
so now i'm going to move on to the
second condition sculptures b and c must
be in the same room
so this is similar
but now applied to b and c
um
b and c and they have to be in the same
room so i'm just going to return b
equals c
so i'm going to check that that factor
does what i wanted to do so it's happy
with one one and two two
which is good
and now what about the final condition
so room two can hold only one sculpture
this one's a little bit tricky because
it doesn't mention
sculptures exactly it mentions only the
room
but here what it really means is that i
have to look at all
the sculpture variables
so i'm going to define a factor let's
call it r2
which depends on all the variables here
and i'm going to need to figure out
whether room 2 has
at most one sculpture so let's keep a
counter
and we're going to go through all the
the sculptures and see if sculpture a is
in room 2 if it is i'm going to
increment the counter
if
sculpture b is in room 2 i'm going to
increment the counter if sculpture c is
in room through i'm going to increment
the counter
and now i'm going to return whether the
number of sculptures in room 2 which is
now n
is at most 1.
okay so i make that factor
and i can see that
this factor is happy if
at most
one
sculpture is in room 2 or 0.
okay so now
i have defined my constraint
satisfaction problem or factor graph set
of variables set of factors
and now if i press step
then it will magically solve
the the csv
and here there is one
satisfying assignment which assigns um a
to room two
um signs b and c to room one
okay so that's our first example of
solving a constraint satisfaction
problem
um here is another example from object
tracking so suppose you're trying to
build an autonomous driving system
you want to track where objects are such
as cars and pedestrians so you know
where not to drive
so we're going to
work with a very simplified
setup here
and here the setting is we're going to
have a number of discrete time steps 0 1
2
3 4. and in each time step we're going
to have a sensor observation that tells
us
um a noisy indicator of the position of
a particular object so maybe at time
step one i'm going to observe that the
object was at
zero
and that's time step two
um i get observation of two and at times
f3 i'm going to get observation of
2. so the noisy centers report these
positions 0 to 2.
and we know that objects
can't teleport
um so the question is what trajectory
did the object take
did it do something like this and
actually the sensor readings were
correct or maybe it did something like
that or something completely different
so how do we do this
we're going to set up a object tracking
csp
so let's first define a factor graph
the variables of the factor graph are
going to include the position of the
object at each time step um
one two or three there's three time
steps
and the domain of each variable is a
zero one or two so object could be in
position zero one or two so x i
represents the true position of the
object at time step i
so now we're going to define a bunch of
observation factors and this is going to
be attempting to
incorporate the sensor information into
the problem
so remember um at time step
one we observed that the object was zero
of course this is noisy so we don't want
to trust it completely we're going to
find an observation factor o1 that
captures this
so o1 is going to be a unifac urinary
factor depends on only on x1
and it's going to highly favor assigning
x1 to 0 which is the actual observation
but if x1 might be at 1 which is a
neighboring location
that's going to have a weight of 1.
and if the object is too
far away
then a 2 then i'm going to say that's
disallowed so whenever you see a 0
weight
a factor returning 0 that's saying
that's a
veto okay so um
o2 is similar but applied to um
you know x2
x2 is remember the position of the
object at time step two
um and it's going to favor x2 being 2
and degrade if it's a 1 away and forbid
it if it's 2 away
x 3 is also similar but applied to x3
which is the object position at times f3
it's going to favor x3 equal to but also
going to degrade and forbid if it's too
far away
okay so we have three observation
factors that capture the sensor readings
and now we're going to define
transition factors which represent the
fact that objects positions can't change
too much or in other words objects can't
teleport
so here we're going to write this factor
a little bit differently
it's going to be a little bit more
compact so we're going to look at the
absolute difference between
an
object at
time step i and an object at the next
time step i plus
and if the object hasn't moved which
means that the difference is zero i'm
going to assign a weight of two
if it's moved by one then i'm going to
assign a weight of one and if it's moved
by two i'm going to sign a weight of
zero which is you know disallowing it
okay so this concludes the definition of
the constraint satisfaction problem for
this simple object tracking
example
if i click on the demo
i'll show
i can see that the
what the cfc looks like in javascript
code i've defined three variables x1 x2
x3
i'm going to define this helper function
nearby
that returns 2 if a and b are equal 1 if
they're 1 apart and 0 if they're 2 apart
and then i'm going to define these
factors o1
o2 o3 and
t1 and t2
so if i um
solve this
csp this will return all the
the set of
non-zero
weight assignments and i'll see the
maximum weight assignment is one two two
so this is a solution to a csp it's
assigning x one one x two two and x
three two
um looking at this picture it's uh one
two two so
we think that the object probably took
this path
okay so
that's the end of this example
so now let's look at a third example
event scheduling so csps are really
suited for generally scheduling problems
so here is an example of a simple
scheduling problem so you have a set of
events
and that need to be assigned into a
number of time slots
so the events are numbered one through e
and the time slots are number one
through t
um so we have three conditions here the
first condition is that each event must
be put in exactly one time slot
condition two says that each time slot
can have at most one event so you can't
double book two events into one time
slot
and then condition three says
that event
e is allowed in time slot t
only if
this pair is exists in a set of allowed
pairs so i can visualize a as a set of
edges between the events and the time
slots and here is one
possible assignment i assign
event 1 to time slot 2
assign
event 2 to time slot 1 and assign event
3 to time slot 3.
notice that i can't assign event to time
slot 2 because that would violate
c3 there's no edge between
event 2 and time slot 2.
okay so how are we going to model this
as a csp i'm actually going to show you
not one but two
possible formulations of the csp which
goes to show that there's some
flexibility or you can say artistic
you know license in terms of how you
decide to
formulate problems with csps
okay so the first formulation is going
to be looking at it from the events
perspective
so here i'm going to define a set of
variables for each variable each event e
i'm going to define a variable
x e
and the domain of
xe is going to be
some integer 1 through t
so notice here that right off the bat
i've satisfied condition c1
because in a csp
every variable has to take on exactly
one value
and so that means that each
event will be put in exactly one time
slot
so what about c2 now i have to do
something for c2
notice that c2 is in terms of time slots
but you know our variables are in terms
of events
so if you remember from the lz puzzle
that means we implicitly have to define
a factor that looks at all
possible variables here
so i'm going to define a constraint
which is for
on every pair of events um
i'm going to make sure that
um the
the time slot that event e was assigned
is not the same as the
time slot that event e prime was
assigned
so if i check this for all pairs of
events
now i've satisfied a c2 i can guarantee
that no time slot has two events piling
onto it
okay so now what about c3 so each event
must be only allowed in certain time
slots
so here again i'm going to look at each
possible event
and i'm simply going to enforce that
whatever time slot event e was assigned
that's denoted x e
that pair is in the set of allowed event
time slot pairs
and that's enough to satisfy condition
three
okay so that's the first formulation of
the csp
so now let's look at
alternative formulation
so now i'm going to look at from the
perspective of time slots
so here i'm going to define a variable
um yt for every possible time slot t
and yt can take on a
value which is either one of the
possible events or
no which means that no events have been
assigned to that time slot
so notice here right off the bat i've
satisfied condition 2
because
remember every variable gets assigned
one
exactly one value which is either going
to be event or no event so you can't
possibly assign two events to a time
slot
now now we have to deal with
condition one so how do we deal with it
so here
um
all variables are in terms of time slots
but uh condition one is in terms of
events so again we're going to have to
define
um a constraint that touches all the
variables
so for every event here
i need to enforce that
if i look over all the time slots
that
that event shows up exactly once
so what this is saying is that
this factor looks at all y1
through
yt
and checks that
yt equals
y little t equals e for exactly one of
the possibilities
so this will check the box for c1
and now c3 is similar to before
so for every time slot we're going to
enforce that either
nothing was selected at that time slot
or if something were a schedule that
that event
and that time slot are compatible
okay so that concludes the definition of
the second formulation
and now one might wonder which one is
better
and this is um
you know a matter of efficiency and
there's various trade-offs which are
discussed more in the notes
okay so here is a final example of a csp
which is going to be a little bit
different and um so it will be kind of
interesting
so this is program verification
so everyone writes programs and you're
probably used to the idea of writing
unit tests to check whether a program is
correct
but just because you program past a
bunch of tests doesn't actually
guarantee that it's correct because
you're never sure that you covered all
the cases
so behind the idea behind program
verification is to prove that your
program works for all possible inputs
so let's work through a simple example
suppose you have this program foo which
takes in two values x and y
and it computes the following
so it's gonna assign
x times x to a
it's going to add y times y to a and
then assign that to b
and then it's going to subtract this
quantity and assigned to the c and
return c
so
the thing i want to prove here is this
following specification that c
is greater than u or equal to zero no
matter what value x and y take
so here is how i'm going to specify the
csp
i'm going to define a set of variables
that corresponds to both the inputs and
also the intermediate quantities that
are computed along the way so x y a b
and c
and now i'm going to define a set of
constraints
corresponding to the program statements
which are going to relate these
variables
and so for the first constraint i'm
going to have a equals x squared which
captures what this first statement is
doing
i'm going to have b equals a plus y
squared which is going to capture the
second program statement and c equals b
minus 2 x y which is going to capture
the third
program statement
so an important but really subtle note
is that equals means two things here
so in the python program
equal is an assignment operator it says
take the right-hand side compute its
value and then put it in the variable
that is on the left-hand side
whereas in the csp
equal represents mathematical equality
it's saying whether um the left-hand
side is equal to the right-hand side
so
you'll remember what this factor don't
be c deceived what the
by the looks of this actor is actually a
function
that takes in a value of a
and a value of x and checks whether a
equals x squared it returns a 1 or a 0.
so it's doing checking whereas a equals
x
times x is doing assignment it's taking
x squared and putting into a
so now there's a final constraint for
this specification and this is also kind
of interesting
no note that we wanted to check that
c is greater than 0 for all x and y but
we're going to negate that here because
csvs were doing um only looking for an
existence
of a particular assignment and csps
can't um
you know natively check all possible
you know
assignments in a sense
um so we're going to negate it so
intuitively what this is doing is
looking for a counter example it's going
to say hey can we find a setting of x y
a b and c such that we are able to find
c less than or equal to 0.
and
you know if we can
that means um the
the specification doesn't hold there's a
counter example
but if we are not able to find any
consistent
assignment if the csp is not satisfiable
that means the program satisfies the
specification
so it's maybe a little bit counter to it
at first but we're proving
correctness
based on the fact that the csp has no
satisfying assignments
so one thing that's really kind of cool
and interesting about
formulating the program as a csp and the
fact that this mathematical equality is
not uh it's bi-directional
is that the csp can actually reason
in no particular order it can look start
with this constraint c less than zero
and it can work backwards it can look
backwards through c b n a or it can look
forwards
starting with x and y or it can do it in
kind of a more sophisticated order
whereas if you were only to execute the
program you can only go forwards so this
shows you kind of the flexibility and
power of
reasoning over programs using a
constrained satisfaction problem
okay so we've presented a number of
examples of real world problems and show
you how to formulate them as a csp or
two
so how do you do it well first step is
to decide on the variables and the
domains and you want to check that an
assignment to all these variables gives
you
the result of interest
and then we take a look at all the
zerata the constraints and the
preferences the wishes
and translate them into a set of factors
and the nice thing about csps is that
this process is often paralyzable
so if you have a set of disjointer
usually each digital rod term translates
into a factor or a set of factors and
then at the end of the day you just
throw in all the factors into your csp
so there are some
notes to keep in mind when you're
designing a constraint satisfaction
problems you should keep the csps small
so that they will be more
computationally efficient to solve
so which means either having fewer
variables uh fewer
factors a smaller number of uh domains
um smaller number of errors you can't
make everything small but and there's
various trade-offs
exactly
what exactly is the recipe for uh
computational efficiency really depends
on the problem there's no kind of
general rule
so this is going to be a little bit of
art here
and finally one just kind of reminder is
that when you think about implementing
each factor
you know it is true that each factor is
itself a little mini program but you
should really think of in terms of
checking a solution
checking whether assignment to the the
variables of that factor
encompasses is valid rather than trying
to compute the solution
so equals is mathematical equality
rather than
assignment and this is really important
and it takes a little bit of getting
used to because csps requires a
fundamentally different mindset than
normal
kind of procedural programming
which is most salient in the program
verification example
um but you know hopefully after a bit of
practice you'll get um used to how
thinking in terms of csps and hopefully
will become more second nature
all right so that's the end of this
module